so firstly would you like to introduce
yourself and tell us a little bit about
your role on Jack Reacher well my name
is henry jackman and i was the composer
for the score for the movie Jack Reacher
never go back which is the second in the
franchise for those out there who may
not know what that means well it's funny
you mention that I remember talking to a
friend of my mother's right who had my
mom doesn't have like that much interest
in what I do for a living and she had a
friend who when when it was explained to
her oh you know so so Diane's son ie me
does the music for film she goes oh I
thought I thought when you do a movie
the music comes with the film you know
like the batteries to a toy or something
so for anyone who doesn't know how it
works no that is not the case the music
obviously does not come in the film
there is a movie there's sometimes a
temp track and then you spend one spends
anything from three months to a year
writing all the music for the film
that's a really good question it it
often depends sometimes it's good to
having read the script and having seen
the movie step away from picture maybe
sometimes just put a still or a series
of stills up and write self-contained
pieces away from picture to sort of make
discoveries you don't have spent too
long doing that because those ultimately
won't be the cues for the film but it's
somewhere in the middle you know either
want to spend so too long in a sort of
abstract space of writing separate
sweets away from picture but on the
other hand if you just launch straight
in to the picture and doing specific
music to the scenes you sometimes
haven't made all the discoveries you
need to make and you'll end up coming
back and revisiting and reworking stuff
and it would have been good to be away
from picture just to find your colors
and your harmonies and your theme and
your texture because necessarily when
you worked a picture because of the the
not the restrictions but the the what's
dictated to you by the mechanics of the
scene you will necessarily have to craft
and follow that and if you're in the
early stages of trying to find your
motifs and themes you don't want to be
held by
back by that to start with you want to
let music follow its own sort of
self-justifying you know root and and
it'll lead you to certain discoveries
and ones I mean I just find you sort of
know when that point is it would be a
bit like the difference between I don't
know if you were a chef you know rather
if there was a really important meal
with ten people showing up instead of
just literally cooking that one meal you
might want to just have a sort of
practice run where you do you just do a
couple of rows to see what's going on
and then you can be extremely specific
about who's gonna be eating what later
but it's good to be a pop anything else
the other good thing about it is you
have a greater sense of freedom for
experimentation because it doesn't
matter if something's don't work so you
sometimes end up pursuing a musical
thing to its conclusion because it had
its own sort of request for internal
logic and you followed there and then it
may be something that in the ultimate
analysis isn't that useful for the film
anyway but you had that but there was no
panic about that because you were in
this sort of abstract space of trying to
find things when you're working to
picture of something doesn't work it
like what ales and is working you know
it seems it seems more stressful yes
exactly that's a very good point meaning
in order to know I mean if you're going
for a walk it could be interesting to
know that if you know that that path you
know doesn't go to the river and it
starts climbing that probably means that
other one back that you know that we
missed last time that's probably the one
that head south you know you discover
something by you know we've been down
that road and we know that doesn't work
for this particular movie that's that's
as valuable a partly us it's also a good
thing when you have nagging doubts
there's there's nothing more annoying
ago I wonder I wonder if it might have
been cool had we had gone down this road
you know what happens if we blah blah
blah and instead of going well I guess
we'll never know that might have been a
brilliant night so no no no I remember I
tried that it was rubbish
you don't mean we've been down that road
and it doesn't work so it is good in the
early stages I always think that you'll
end up with something if you go if you
just start writing straight away to
picture you're likely to go for
something a little safer a little more
known and and whilst the music and the
keys might be well-crafted
you're less likely to have made
a slightly interesting discovery that
can then apply to the whole school
actually in the case of Jack Reacher it
was more a case of deconstruction
because I had us remember having a
Samantha theme that even as I'd finished
here I knew it was a little bit on the
elaborate side for this particular sort
of meet Jack Reacher is a long way from
Harry Potter in in sort of symphonic
style you know and and I had a Samantha
idea and I remember playing it to Ed and
and we sort of delved into it just keep
scraping away the bits we didn't need
til we got it down to these to use a
pretentious poetic time couplets you
know these two it was a little over
lyrical in a movie where Samantha's sort
of character arc was not legends of the
fall it wasn't some giant romance or
anything and I had a slightly over
develop lyrical theme but it was a real
interesting process because you know I
mean Eddie was so chipping away at mean
we ended up finding the the more
tentative deconstructed version of it so
that that's a good example of you start
with something that in that case is a
little it'd be like you've got a big hog
roast and you got the hug but you don't
need all of it you know you end up
slicing bits off you know it's not like
everyone has to eat everything yes I
think so I think that that would be a
fair surmise because I think what's
what's it what's interesting about Ed's
wag was everyone knows it means a really
established director but it's not just
these established he's established with
with a unquestionable dramatic integrity
that's what I mean you know if you think
about some things as weak started out in
the last film I saw was porn sacrifice
but I don't know last time you write
letters to the fool that there's there's
a if you're gonna hire Ed's work you've
in the bag already coming you know with
the package is a dramatic sureness of
touch now and that's like what hold on
because this is Jack Reacher so Jack
Reacher's obviously can have action and
espionage and you know all the sorts of
things you associate with it but
actually in this particular movie as
well as there I'm not saying there's
anything right if you made a move
be that's an action film and and it's
tightly put together and has the sort of
aspect of thriller to that that's that's
a genre that works but what I liked
about this story which I you know ed was
also involved in the writing is as well
as the things you expect from from a
Jack Reacher movie there's there's a
dramatic element in it which is great
for the composer and I think it's great
for the movie I mean I don't know people
are so used familiar with all of Tom
Cruise's achievements in the action
genre I mean it just it is endless it
goes back to you know Top Gun and
sometimes people forget that this is the
same guy Jerry Maguire Magnolia born on
the 4th of July I mean we're talking
about he the man's got some serious
dramatic chops it's just you don't
always need them if you're hanging off
the side of an airplane in an action
film and what's what's great about this
film is you still get the action hero
but because of the other story in the
film with Samantha it's an opportunity
for everyone the writers of the movie
Tom Cruise that there's a type of
dramatic acting in there and for me is
the composer it opens up this musical
avenues so that you can have a bit of
counterpoint in the score so on the one
hand there is some really pulsating
action music and there's the sort of
tension music you'd expect to get in an
espionage thriller type movie but then
there's this whole other story line
about Samantha I can't give too much
away about the story but there's there's
a empathetic and dramatic story line
that I think hugely enriches the film
and is and it's great for me as a
composer because you get this whole
other strand where the onus isn't on
adrenaline and and sort of keeping
people on the edge of their seats it's
more expressive and I think I did a
great job with that and he saw it
through because you know he there was
Paulette he's part of the writing
process and as a director that's very
much within his you know within his
grass I mean there's certain directors
who are known for doing that amazing
action sequences who perhaps would be a
bit less comfortable with handling how
to kind of sneak the drama in there but
I think he managed to sort of
but all boiling at the same time which
is great meaning you don't expect that
well the one way I'd sum it up when I
first saw the preview I was really
surprised at the thing I remember most
is I really teared up at the end which
is probably what you'd expect if I don't
know I mean every Disney movie they get
you somewhere don't they I mean at the
beginning of our poor in the big hero 6
I there's always a moment where you
better get ready because they're gonna
hit you with something where you start
to it's probably not the first thing you
expect from a Jack Reacher movie but
watch out would be my advice because you
may find yourself tearing up in it don't
forget the Birth of a Nation that's
right because uh because I don't figure
oh yeah he does action feels like maybe
attract you to the project or vice versa
what is it about your sort of talent and
and the way you compose music that well
right so with Captain America if you
take for example Captain America I the
second or the third one I think what's
appealing from a film composer point of
view and so many things you could think
of like whether it be TV or more
intimate film projects where you've got
to keep a pretty low profile and
actually that's a good thing in itself
and I don't know I've done I recently
did The Birth of a Nation which is a
very different kind of school to those
sorts of things we're talking about but
the I would say the benefit of some of
these big screen big action things is
it's all it's always encouraged to be
sort of ambitious as it were meaning
I'll give you an example at the end of
Captain America 3 there's a pretty
serious fight going on at the end and
it's sort of internal fights not one of
those giant you know 50,000 orcs versus
a lot of horse when it's between Iron
Man Winter Soldier and Captain America
and it's sort of almost a bit Mount
Olympus it's a bit like Zeus versus you
know it's almost like the Roman gods are
having a big old scrap on the top of the
mountain kind of thing and so you get to
write you know
I pitch to the Rousseau's that surely
instead of this being you know just
pumping adrenaline actually this is
operas and yeah I allowed to kind of
comment what the CD tracks cause it's
called clash or something yeah wouldn't
this be the moment where I'm allowed to
get pretty operatic about this fight
because it's not regular it's not three
people having a scrap in a bar where the
music I wrote for that scene would be
vastly pretentious and popular why am i
hearing this sort of huge operatic piece
with three men having a brawl in a bar
but if it's a you know a superhero movie
having a titanic fight between these
sort of totemic superheroes means that
you are allowed to use quite grandiose
musical language which in all frankness
I don't know where else he would use if
if you've had a musical education that
does include sort of Strauss and Muller
and opera and all the rest of it you
don't really need that in any sort of
pop music you certainly wouldn't need
that in a kind of modern TV show like
where are the outlets for sort of grand
symphonic music well you know the finale
of Captain America would be a good
example of one so you get to you get to
do things that you you you other I'm
trying to think where else you would do
them if yeah if you were frustrated
symphonic in in a world where not
everyone wants big symphonic music kind
of thing and why should they there's all
sorts of brilliant film schools there
are many miles away from big symphonia
stuff and in fact I've done some of
those myself
having said that if it weren't for say
the genre of the superhero movies and
just films in general I'm not sure where
that would find an outlet what so I was
gonna use a word to describe because
it's so you mean that climax yeah
exactly but not only in the stakes high
it's not psychologically realistic you
can have a scene like in a Michael Mann
movie where the stakes are really high
and three people might end up in a fight
and you can't do a cue like I did in
Captain America said why am i hearing
this great grant what are they gods or
something this is ridiculous
because you know it'll be it's set in
contemporary Los Angeles but when the
setting is not regular and these are you
know the whole that's kind of secretly
why I like superheroes in a way because
this is gonna sound really pretentious
but for
whatever reason in 19th century Germany
the reason why and by the way I'm not
comparing myself to real composers like
Strauss I'm just talking about a
cultural thing for whatever reason it
was de rigueur and quite a normal thing
for composers to write these grand tone
poems cool things I'm held in labor now
suspect sounds rooster and that was like
the culture and for whatever isn't you
know German middle-class people would
listen to that and so it was an accepted
thing that people would write these huge
grandiose symphonic pieces that would be
listened to in consoles well you know I
don't think you're gonna get a record
deal these days where I was thinking of
writing a grand sixty two minute work
called the hero and it would be you know
envy like well you know I'm not signing
it you know whereas that finds a home
funnily enough that the some of the
obvious lineage for that type of write
isn't obviously not as good composition
as Strauss but the type of Ella wasn't
just a wine back then what I'm really
saying is weirdly enough having
superheroes opens the gate to that kind
of symphonic writing because superheroes
aren't normal people you are allowed a
more elevated symphonic language that
makes sense and stead of people thinking
college is pretentious and ridiculous as
it would if you try to put it in Syriana
or something like realistic or modern
the whole genre of the superhero when
you've got a titanic clash between sort
of Captain America and Iron Man and it's
about whether the whole idea of a
superhero should or shouldn't be
accountable to human society in general
and they these are all such kind of
elevated ideas that don't happen on a
Monday morning in most people's regular
lives that it asks for a type of
symphonic language which sort of harks
back a bit to these big you know
austro-german it composers so I'm
nowhere near as good as any of them I'm
just saying it's the only time you can
steal some stuff from there and put it
in movies and and it works in a way that
just wouldn't I mean Jack Reacher if you
try to do that that wouldn't that would
be completely the wrong approach how do
you think the soundtrack and the
composition of the music lends
to add into that effect mmm well the
funny thing almost be time to think of
it the other way around the often when
you're working on writing music
you're not in a no you're not in an IMAX
cinema there you use it you know I got a
home studio it's got a pretty decent
screen and you can sometimes you often
have to remember the extra perspective
that happens once you get into a serious
you know once once you're listening and
viewing arena is for real and it's an
IMAX screen and you're actually the
cinema you mustn't forget that because
often you'll be working day by day by
day and you're not in that environment
and it does make a difference and it
makes a difference too as a composer
sometimes to the level of ambition you
might have about something because you
might be working on something go well
you know I maybe should I don't know if
this scene necessarily merits this level
of heightened tension or this level of
emotional death because there you are
staring at a screen looking like this
and then sometimes I'll go to a preview
which isn't even that's not even IMAX
you know it's just a regular screen and
go oh wow what was I thinking it's this
is a really big deal this scene it's
just it's it's a different experience
now I'm seeing it all so funnily enough
the the intended the you should always
keep an eye on the intended you know i
that's not to say everyone watches i
cost loads of people watching on planes
and laptops and these days iPhones but
it makes a huge make use of it and it
also affects how you it also affect how
you mix things at the table that's just
that the the having the fullest expanse
both of screen and these days with Atmos
as well means I think it means you pay a
little more attention you've got more to
play with you can move I mean even just
on a technical level I mean we need to
live a mixers to the dub stage these
days it's in so many bits now because
you can put it in so many different
places but I think
the leaving leaving IMAX aside for a
second the the experience should always
be one hopefully that the audience don't
notice you know what I mean and I feel
like with IMAX I got even more room to
be manipulative in a funny way because
it's so visually spectacular I mean in a
way it goes back to like the biggest
compliment annoyingly in a way for fun
composers that
oh yeah the music I didn't and think
about I mean not quite but at least you
haven't you haven't jolted people out of
the narrative you were enhancing it
sufficiently hopefully throughout - no
one had that experience I feel that I'm
access is even more immersive so you
really got to commit a crime musically
to pull people out of the visual
narrative and the dialogue you you're
gonna have to commit a sin of pretty
epic proportions for people to be you
know sitting in front of something that
visually magnificent and then be
dislocated and distracted unless on
those few occasions when you you are
called upon deliberately to unsettle and
dislocate people but it just makes it
it's just an added level of immersion
really that that I welcome if only
everyone watched it you know I'd much
rather every one of which wants things
on IMAX rather iPhones and the backs of
airplane seats yeah you know when you
watch a film on IMAX it's what the
filmmakers intended right and you do
know you you often happens is you know
to some details I mean even just in the
IMAX it's not exactly linked but I mean
it tends to be the case that IMAX
cinemas do not have lousy sound systems
you know what I mean and you even start
to notice I mean not everyone's a
complete audio geek but I don't think
you have to be without knowing why
you're noticing different things I even
feel like just the nuances of people's
delivery make things clearer and make
things you may even pick up on what a
lot of people are obviously going to
screens that big a movie feels very
visual and it feels that a person's
acting is very
visual and as long as you're hearing the
dialogue and you understand what it
means but don't forget so much of in
addition to seeing all the detail of
people's expressions and little subtle
things that might be handy you didn't
quite notice before even in also with
the sound when the sounds that much
better as well you'll get little nuances
and people's dialogue performance where
they're just you hear the sarcasm a
little bit more you hear you know and
especially with you know close-up shot
someone know you'll get you get so much
acting in facial expression expression
that you could literally not even pick
up on if it's not a laptop or something
and you know who really affect us actors
I mean if you're overacting you are
gonna get seriously found out in IMAX
where's the slightest little facial
gesture you know it's a big deal you
know close-up shot in IMAX is you could
probably do most of what you need to
achieve with your nostrils I mean yeah
exactly so with Jack Reacher why do you
think this movie merits going to see it
in IMAX well I would first of all it it
looks there's a certain I don't know how
to describe it I'm not really a expert
on cinematography cool adjectives it's
got well firstly why wouldn't you write
but secondly there is there is a there's
sort of two things about it that I think
are interesting one is there's a sort of
earthy classiness to it the I don't know
why that would particularly merit that
the scale and the size but I would
rather see it like that and secondly
there's a viscera in the in the action
and the movement as a lot of there's a
lot of people fleeing and being chased
in this film and I feel like that that
the scale of that is in its correct
context you know with with a huge screen
I though yeah I mean yeah sound there's
dynamic range oh yeah well that's yeah I
mean one of the things that I love about
film use is unlike the record industry
where
everyone is spending all their time
trying to make everything kind of
dynamically level and max out as loud as
possible all the time the great thing
about movies is kind of the opposite
you'll have everything in movies from
like the quietest stillest moment and
then a massive crescendo and you know
this huge dynamic range which puts an
onus on the system that you're listening
to the better the system the more it's
it's like a symphony orchestra can go
from you know just a flute and the
tiniest pianist a mo temp to like full
tutti Orchestra and that sounds
fantastic when you're in the Walt Disney
Concert Hall that having the capacity to
have such an amazing dynamic range is
what is part of the experience and so
that's great in a decent cinema and you
know IMAX screen you'll get all of that
I mean I remember writing cues where
just before the action kicks off it's
sort of tailing down tailing down
tailing down and it's like pianist most
the sort of level where in 1972 you
might even be in to sort of take this by
this point you know you'll start to hit
and then it all kicks off and you know
that all the gags like the lull before
the storm and the kind of the misdirect
and then the action kicks off all of
those kind of things having the correct
or the most elevated reproduction system
whether it's visual audio just means
that all of these things that you're you
know manipulating the audience with who
I live alike crazy because it's the best
tools to play back on you know it was
pretty smooth right because Aaron I'd
had you know we were very creatively in
sync I think if anything I think that
very opening cue was it was a teaser was
a tester because it was a it was an
interesting way around when I first
wrote the opening cue it was somewhat
neutral it's a little bit procedural and
and then by the time I got to the end of
the movie I then wrote this extremely
emotional piece for the end and I was
like wow it's there anyway
clearly it can't be as emotionally
resolved as that cuz that's the end of
the movie but there's something about
the beginning of the movie where he's
trying to connect you even though he's
very sort of emotionally detached that
the opening scene just has little
suggestions of him trying to reach out
and and so there well you know maybe
there's a universe where there is
something in motion about the first key
and it took a while cuz then then I
wrote one that was at way too emotional
it's like okay no well that's not it's
somewhere between a kind of thrill estro
action neutrality on the one hand and
this other thing which feels too
emotionally developers promise too much
when we don't really know all of the
characters of the film there's there's
something about here that hasn't been
written yet so finding that was an
interesting one but I'm very proud we
ventually found it I think that was the
challenge well I would in an idea in a
sort of platonic universe the most
important thing is is composition and
ideas and I still think that is true the
only thing I would say is it being 2016
people need to hear things before
they're finished before they wrote fully
mix before as a real Orchestra on it so
actually there are so many unlike say
1950 where as long as you have a piece
of Muscat paper and a pencil a director
with imagination a piano some trust and
a conversation the next time you might
hear it might be at the scoring stage
you know those days are gone so they're
gonna hear everything so having a quite
extensive set of what you might consider
technical skills you know programming
programming simply or just a sound like
a symphony orchestra being good at mix
if you want to do hybrid movies really
knowing what you're doing with
electronic um being how to put
everything together and balance it and
all the rest of it you would think that
all about this is all technical is it
well you say that other than if you have
a meeting scenario a very badly so
imagine the idea of the piece is pretty
much the same thing scenario a over here
poorly programmed orchestra with bad
samples with slightly badly put to put
together electronica mixed poorly will
produce the following reaction yeah no I
don't think this is that this is what
this isn't really working scenario be
pretty much
the same compositional idea all done
executed problem oh this is fantastic
yeah like this this is great and that
isn't so so in 2016 you suddenly boat
now that's not to say that the danger
with there is that you can end up with
people who can advance quite a long way
in their career who are able to make
things sound rather good but if you
scrape away under the bonnet in terms of
actual composition there's not really
much there but its presentational ii
it's fantastic in an ideal world both
happening at the same time and if you're
gonna go outside of just the symphony
orchestra then a lot of these skill
because ultimately mocking up and all
just one thing because eventually it
gets played anyway so it's gonna be real
but if it's not orchestral then all
these things are for it that's what
you're going to hear in the cinema all
the textual lecture it's not like oh
well we're just sort of messing around
with it because it's going to be done
you know properly later this is it
whatever the the textual stuff you're
working on that is not oku sztyc is what
millions of people are going to hear in
the cinema so it can't be lame so i
would say ultimately the most important
thing about being a film composer is
really it's almost in a funny way it's
literary criticism skills it's
understanding a story breaking it down
and being able to come up with ideas
they know it's a story that's in some
sort of abstract area intellectual but
that's the most important thing then
once you start implementing then a lot
of these skills are really important you
could easily imagine a scenario where
someone who is in fact very gifted but
lacking many skills to to make it able
to be presented unfortunately
imagination for sound has gone down a
bit since we're all able to make things
sound pretty damn good before right so
these days when people hear things you
know you put spacebar portals and it's
pretty much like what I'm hearing is
what I'm reacting to I'm not projecting
something I might be hearing in the
future you know just play it to me now
and what I'm hearing is what I'll react
to so it would be sad you know for
anyone who is potentially very skillful
composer who's thinking oh I'm not going
to bother with any any technical well
that's fine if you want to be like a
concert composer and you everything's
fine just get paper in you can get some
guys to program stuff up but if you want
to do some
work in the industry that's going to be
with TV and film and video games and
whatnot it would be a real shame if you
do have compositional talent to be held
back because you don't in other words if
you're sitting on the fence with all
shall I do this like mixing or shall I
you know figure out how to use logic or
Cuba so the answer is yes you should
yeah that's not to say it's the most
important thing because on the other
hand I can hear and I hear too much of
it something that's presentational II
well-engineered well make still rested
but there's some yeah if you actually go
to a piano go
well what composition wise what's
happening here not very much you know so
ideally both no it's a right exactly
exactly so IMAX itself is coming up on
its 50th anniversary oh wow
and let's see how he's mesh he
definitely done a lot to sort of change
the industry always you know about 15
years ago we started projecting
Hollywood films and you know in movie
theaters whereas before it was mainly
these like you know documentary films
right into space or National Geographic
so you know how has that sort of over
those decades changed audiences
experiences of film well that's an
interesting question I think it also
goes back to a question about you like
why why do you like to go see IMAX
movies that I think you but well it's
what's interesting about that I guess I
mean the order the history and origin of
imax is that you would see these often
you know things from the natural world
or from space or something so the idea
being because we've got this these
incredible dimensions to play with it
it's mostly been things that are purely
visually spectacular what why I think
it's great that the the transition was
made to you know big films going to I
might've said well hold on a minute just
things can be both visually spectacular
and also bonus have a really good story
so if anything I mean the ultimate use
of IMAX would be that where you're
killing two birds with one stone
I mean it's great I mean I don't know
let's think it's not a riddle II Scott
there's a good example Ridley Scott
movies it you know you could just switch
them off and let them run in the
background and they're all I mean it's
like a moving painting I mean I'm sure
some people have Ridley Scott movies
they prefer to others but you'll never
be able to say they don't look good you
know I think all of his movies are great
right but their vision they're
inherently it's part of his style he's a
very visual I mean go look at Blade
Runner and alien all that these movies
are visually spectacular but they're not
just to stare at you know at the same
time alien is just that you can hardly
bear the tension and it's an amazing
story as well so why wouldn't you if a
nature documentary is allowed to be you
know on IMAX I would say that something
that alien would be you know twice twice
as worthy of being you know of being
viewed in an IMAX situation because
you're getting I think it comes back to
what we're talking about before about
the story because it's not just a canvas
like a painting it's an environment
where a story is being told
only guess what now we've got like the
biggest versus so the visual aspect of
it will be the most spectacular but
what's great about movies is is you know
it's it's it's almost like that and if
you go by thousands of years it's like
the fart it's the Bard
telling the stories by the fire only
it's said the most technologically
advanced version where it looks
absolutely incredible but you know if
you can have a documentary then then I
think triple time triple times that you
can have you know you can have a movie
because you get you know story plus
spectacle equals